over the last few weeks the corona virus
outbreak has made news headlines around
the world many of the reports of laughs
viewers readers and listeners confused
and afraid as to the dangers that could
lie had with the continued spread of the
virus the happy accusations from several
groups including health care
professionals these reports are
inflammatory and headline-grabbing
rather than a true reflection of the
situation currently the mortality rate
of the corona virus around 2% with a
majority of those infected having mild
to moderate symptoms and making a good
recovery of course we're in the early
days of the epidemic and we are learning
more and more about the corona virus as
each day passes but the media should be
more responsible and conscious of the
impact of their reporting whatever the
media is doing they've been incredibly
successful in my eyes at scaring me
about the potential risk of the corona
virus because I actually have flights
booked to go to China I'm doing to
Shanghai going up to Beijing and coming
out of Hong Kong and there is no way
that I would take those lights there is
nothing that could convince me to take
that trip quite frankly because I would
rather be safe than sorry so are they
are the media potentially overreacting
possibly but where's the harm in that
because if what they're doing is they're
getting you to think about whether it's
your personal hygiene if you think that
you might be at risk of something
whether it's about you concealing your
your mouth and your nose where you're
coughing and sneezing you know there's
no real harm to that and I think the
World Health Organization has put out a
warning and actually said that this is a
threat and a very real threat so I for
one will take heed of that I wouldn't be
going anywhere near China right now and
as I said I'd rather be safe than sorry
I think the important thing is being
alert I'm anxious so making the public
aware of certain risks and giving advice
but not letting that kind of run away
with it I'll I'll take an example here
in newspaper so this the title of this
is global spread of killer infection
it's got kind of a go red covering of
the mass almost like a you know kind of
games console of yeah and all the deaths
and it's not really a fair
representation what's going on you know
every year the flu kills between 600,000
people in the UK so far you know only
two people have the virus here in the UK
before I yield I'll tell you very
briefly I was on a tube about a week or
so ago and there was one lady stood up
at the end and she had a facial mask on
and there was another lady sitting down
and the lady sitting down coughed how
entire way through with the genic my
first thought was I think someone needs
to give her a bottle of water I could
shoot it was relentless non-stop then I
noticed everyone was looking at each
other getting eye contact one woman got
up and changed carriages I got myself
into such a state I got off the tube a
couple of stops down so it may be a
little bit of every action but as I said
safe well she customized no she wasn't I
found at the height of rudeness in one
day quite having that went from and to I
don't know but I spent most of this week
in York where of course the two cases
were found and I was getting up I could
see no discernible effect upon the
people of you at all they seemed to me
just carrying on as normal and at the
weekend there was that they had a big
event in you which was ice sculptures
all over the city and thousands of
people turned up this was okay we are
talking about the condition more than
20,000 cases 560 people have died
China is effectively in isolation I
appreciate as it's gonna got a Texas
ours had a 10% mortality this is this is
a global event not just health think
economy China in Isis China is worth 20%
of the global economy if China and
they've already downgraded their growth
by 1%
we will this could actually worse case
bring about another recession
so I hear what you're saying and you've
got a valid point but this as we call it
in the older is a bloody good story and
it deserves telling and it is a
worldwide epidemic
I mean masses on Instagram people saying
like I'm going on holiday to Spain next
week so I can
yes that would damage if it continues
colleges universities Chinese students
many of them and if they don't come that
has an effect on the economics of them
as well as you know the whole I mean
come because because when they come the
reason why universities like to have
Chinese I feel sorry for I mean there's
been lots of incidents of people being
very hostile towards Chinese people they
see on the street where those are
wearing masks or not and you're right
about I mean this could be a Black Swan
moment for the global economy the oil
price is down 20%
China is 17% of the global and when
China sneezes the whole world catches a
cold let's hear from some people who are
in Hong Kong and talking about what's it
like there people are escaping from the
hospital so there is no guarantee they
are contouring inside so there is a
danger to our community here we cannot
trust the government we can the trust
does make named are who come here and
they will sneak out definitely and go
and makes into our community to this to
like spread their virus do you hear them
saying you can't trust the Chinese
government as to how serious of the
viruses but can we trust our headlines
as well the masks this is this is the
big point here ready that what
everyone's becoming very afraid buying
all these masks and actually aren't
doing anything at all interestingly
people are buying the masks to protect
themselves from catching the virus but
the one benefit potentially of the mask
is it if you have the infection it might
pass you know they'll do very little for
you if you're walking around and you
haven't got a problem so people are
buying something that's not really worth
anything and a message the message
really should be about the hand hygiene
the idea that you know washing your
hands if you're going to sneeze you
to cover your mouth or and you know you
use a tissue and dispose of it I've got
a mask on surely that's gonna help me if
he or she is sneezing and coffee next to
me surely if I'm wearing a mask I'm not
gonna breathe in those parts because the
particles traveling such like in its
airborne so you just can just make it's
not often that the British government
tells people get out now while you still
can which is what they've said in this
instance Alex Dominic Rob MP foreign
secretary the safety and security of
British people will always be our top
priority as such we now advise British
nationals in China to leave the country
if they can to minimize their risk of
exposure to the virus where there are
still British nationals in who by
province who wish to be evacuated we
will continue to work around the clock
to facilitate this those sort of
evacuations don't come around every day
of the week
we've actually got a clip from someone
who is stuck and misses his nan so could
we hear from him all the group chats are
unknown what's that Facebook all begging
me to come home everybody especially my
mom and my nan there's been no help at
all it's just been drips and drops of
information more than anything and when
you ask them questions on the
information they give you they can't
really elaborate on what they told you
potentially with the virus you've got
people on chemotherapy people otherwise
and well with chest problems we're
putting them at quite high risk so we're
creating little pods or areas in the
department that will go you know this is
someone's high risk they're going in
there for the moment so it is it is
important we are purple was happening
the back and we are preparing for these
things we just want the public at the
moments remaining common so watching my
top tips if you are concerned the main
things to read the papers on don't
listen to me
follow the public health England advice
have a look at the NHS website the
updating it daily and how you use the
most important thing I tell you what
you'll protect yourself as much as you
can against the flu which is you're much
more likely to catch but in the as a
byproduct hopefully you know protect
yourself
Colonel Harris - run for your life run
for your life
stay away from me if you think you've
got it